106 días tuvieron que esperar los
australianos para salir de sus casas al
decretarse el fin de la cuarentena
estricta para combatir el avance de la
variante delta varios habitantes de la
ciudad de sídney madrugaron para
ejercitarse en la playa y para disfrutar
de su nueva libertad bares restaurantes
y comercios también comenzaron a recibir
de nuevo a sus clientes sólo podrán
entrar los que hayan recibido su pauta
completa de vacunación es increíble
poder sentarme y comer algo que he
estado esperando durante un tiempo yo
solo pequeñas cosas las que compensan
gran parte del estrés de estar encerrado
australia ha sido uno de los países con
restricciones más estrictas en el mundo
ahora a pesar de que más del 80% de las
personas mayores de 16 años han recibido
al menos una dosis la apertura de los
colegios y de las fronteras tendrá que
esperar unas semanas
45.000 personas alrededor del mundo
siguen en la lista de espera para poder
regresar a australia clair campbell es
una abogada australiana que vive en
parís y a pesar de tener un cierre de
último momento ha reservado su tiquete
le faltan dos meses para volver a casa
pensaba que iba a volver a casa una o
dos veces al año sin saber que en
realidad iba a estar fuera casi dos años
es una experiencia extraña pero estoy
aliviada de poder volver a casa por fin
desde el comienzo de la pandemia solo 27
mil australianos han podido volver a su
país mediante vuelos de repatriación